I'm Lee Bollinger president of Columbia
agile I want to welcome all of you to
this new york city global partners
summit on urban education and especially
the representatives from 26 cities and
18 different nations who have traveled
to columbia to be here with us this
morning we are happy to be joined on
campus once again by Mayor Michael
Bloomberg and Marjorie tivan a board
member and director of the New York City
global partners she's also an alumna of
Columbia School of Social Work in many
different quarters there is talk today
about globalization the forces it has
unleashed and the consequences for
society in the academic community we are
mindful that with each passing year
globalization is increasing the
complexity of the problems we seek to
understand Columbia University along
with all of our peer institutions is
committed to developing the resources
needed to meet the challenges only by
doing so will we be able to continue to
advance the frontiers of knowledge which
is the central mission of our
universities any listing of the subjects
affected by globalization typically
includes the environment climate change
the economy financial regulation the
study of infectious disease and other
public health issues and this global
partners initiative recognizes that at
its core globalization is an engine of
urbanization throughout the world and
that we have to learn how to better
govern our cities in order to succeed as
a global society too rarely though do we
consider the ways in which globalization
should be changing how we educate our
children today's urban education summit
proves beyond any doubt that by looking
to the experience of other nations and
other cities educators can find a rich
and virtually inexhaustible source of
innovative ideas and practices it is a
resource that must be tapped if we are
to maximize gains in K through 12
education and when we think about the
problems affecting the economies in this
country and throughout the world by far
and away the most important thing we can
do is to build the minds of our children
Columbia is affiliated with teachers
college which was a little more than
ahead of the curve in recognizing the
value of international work because in
1899 it began a program on comparative
and international studies in education
Columbia's engagement in new york city's
public schools is broader than Teachers
College however and we have acknowledged
leadership which goes beyond the
historic role of a local Ivy University
where generations of talented talented
New York City public school graduates
like Joel Klein could get on the subway
in Brooklyn Queens and the Bronx and
take a vital intellectual step on their
journey to this campus and you already
know about ester Fuchs and how engaged
she is with educational policy she's
joined by other faculty members around
here known for their expertise as
scholars and researchers on educational
reform the fact that new york city's
public school system is the largest in
the united states with approximately 1.1
million students in nearly 1,700 schools
is well known but to appreciate the
scale of new york city school system
consider that the population of students
in the city public schools would
constitute on its own
the 10th largest city in the United
States to reform this staggering Lee
large and diverse public school system
Mayor Bloomberg and Chancellor Joel
Klein a Columbia alumnus and I should
add a recipient of an honorary degree
this past may have 48 years committed
themselves to the arduous path of
innovation their reforms have been
discussed passionately debated and
frequently emulated in other cities
around the nation and around the world
this is the fourth consecutive year that
Columbia has co-hosted a summit with the
New York City global partners a
collaboration a series of conferences
which we value greatly mayor feldburg
who for 15 years served as dean of
Columbia's business school and is one of
the most outstanding as Dean's of anyone
I know and who is now president of the
New York City global partners has been
and remains at the heart of this
collaboration and so too is professor
ester Fuchs of Columbia School of Public
and International Affairs I recognize
the moment ago and I want to recognize
them thank them along with the others at
New York City global city city New York
City global partners the office of the
mayor and here at Columbia all the
people who have worked so hard to put on
this summit on urban education it is now
my pleasure to introduce mayor feldburg
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
thank my colleague and friend President
Lee Bollinger for once again inviting us
to his home this is probably one of the
greatest spaces in New York City and it
is always a privilege and an honor to be
in low as it is known around the campus
this conference this event as you heard
from Lee Bollinger is the fourth
consecutive event that Columbia
University is hosted we thank them we
don't take for granted or they do for
the city and we also think the city does
a great deal for Columbia University it
is an extraordinarily synergistic
relationship I would also like to
welcome this morning some of the board
members of New York City global partners
Marjorie Turan who has already been
mentioned and former Mayor David Dinkins
this year we're delighted to see you mr.
mayor Veronica Kelly is here today and
we're very happy to have her with us as
well my toss this morning is to
introduce the mayor of our city Mike
Bloomberg who is now in his ninth year
before I do so I would like to make one
observation that came out of last
night's reception I was talking to the
deputy mayor of the city of Antwerp he
was at last year's conference which was
devoted to job creation in urban areas
he said it was so beneficial that he
came back this year for the education
summit and in fact many went back last
year they made some changes in the city
of Antwerp to the way in which they were
administering and running their job
creation programs so it's always good to
have confirmation that these programs
really do have an impact and really do
work and we're delighted to see so many
cities back again so who do we have here
today we have Antwerp and buena series
Delhi and Edinburgh Edmonton Helsinki
and Hong Kong Jerusalem London and
Luxembourg Manila mexico city in
Montreal New York City Quebec City rio
de janeiro Rome sau Paulo Shanghai
Singapore Taipei tel aviv toronto and
tokyo
truly global event with those brief
observations let me now introduce the
108 mayor of New York City and I would
like to do so with a number and the
number is that during the past year New
York City has accounted for ten percent
of the nation's job growth I say again
in the past year New York City is
accounted for ten percent of the
nation's job growth and of course this
doesn't happen by accident it requires
an enormous amount of vision an enormous
amount of leadership and the capacity to
execute and one of the defining success
factors in Mayor Bloomberg's
administration has been the capacity to
take a vision turn it into a strategy
and actually executed get it done the
mayor understands the end game and the
end game is making it all work and he
has done so extraordinarily well and
i'll talk a little bit about the
educational machinery that that is being
built in created in the city under the
leadership of the mail and joel klein i
also want to mention very briefly of the
mayor doesn't mind that in 1981 he
founded a company with one person namely
himself called bloomberg plc over the
course of the past 30 years Bloomberg
plc is probably employed in and out
maybe forty fifty thousand people has
probably supported four or five hundred
thousand people in a pretty direct way
around the world company operates in 160
cities around the world so we're talking
about a mayor who actually has executed
on an enormous scale and on a global
scale prior to becoming mayor of New
York City now when we talk about
education particularly k through 12 we
tend to focus very much on the students
on the teachers and on the parents in
many ways the end game in fact is the
graduates the students will be students
for 12 years there will be graduates for
75 years and the ultimate success the
ultimate test
the proof of the pudding is how
successful the graduates are when I come
out of the New York City school system
and I think that that it's clear to
everybody who has been involved that
each year over the course of the past
nine years the quality of the graduating
class is improved and each year the
graduating class comes into the city
starts jobs start jobs starts on to
start entrepreneurial programs work in
the public sector and each year they
enhance the quality of the intellectual
property and intellectual capacity in
the city and help the city move forward
so it is all about the graduates but in
order for that to be a success you have
to have an extraordinarily successful k
through 12 program so a couple of data
points and then we'll ask the mayor to
come up and talk to us before Mayor
Bloomberg came to office New York City's
graduation rate had been flat for more
than a decade in the past five years the
graduation rate is increased by
twenty-seven percent Mayor Bloomberg has
also been a leader together with Joel
Klein in moving the city to a point at
which parents and students have far more
choice in the schools that can attend
through the charter school system and
through the vision schools that have
been created Mayor Bloomberg has also
provided an enormous amount of
additional support for the teachers and
teacher salary since he's being mayor
have grown by forty-three percent that
is forty-three percent since 2002 under
Mayor Bloomberg New York City students
have made significant progress on
national assessment of educational
progress that's the NAEP test which is
considered to be the gold standard test
and under Mayor Bloomberg and also under
ray kelly whose wife mrs. Kelly is on
the board of New York City global
partners crime in New York City Schools
has dropped dramatically so with those
brief observations I would like to
invite the 108 mayor of New York City to
address us on urban education K through
well I can't not make the obvious joke
from one mayor to another I thought it's
actually funnier than that but anyways
maiya thank you very much for that kind
introduction it is it's great to be back
here at one of the jewels in the
educational crown of New York City and I
also wanted to thank you for working
with our cities Commission for the
United Nations consular Corps and
protocol headed by my sister
Commissioner Marjorie tivan and also the
New York City Department of Education in
organizing this global partners summit
let me acknowledge the organizations
that have provided support for this
summer because the summit because
without them we couldn't do it Pearson
bank of america the mayor's fund to
advance New York City and of course our
hosts Columbia University led by it's
wonderful President Lee Bollinger and
the entire Columbia community and while
I cannot claim that I ever got a degree
from Columbia University my sister has
it Diana Taylor has two degrees from
Columbia it is a Columbia family whether
I like it or not my allegiances
incidentally are to a small school in
Baltimore but we'll let that go for the
time being also I did want to thank esta
Fuchs Professor X pukes for moderating
this morning's panel on international
school from the school Estes from the
School of International and public
affairs and for four years Esther was my
advisor in City Hall in that capacity
she never let me down she always had
advice for me and it was always special
and sometimes I actually even followed
it not often on behalf of the city of
New York I also wanted to welcome the
delegates from 26 cities and 18 nations
who are attending this summit now I must
confess that if back in my school
teachers in my school days you told the
school teachers in medford massachusetts
that sunday mike bloomberg
all people would be addressing a group
like this from around the world about
improving education they would not have
believed their ears and that's because
they knew me is the kind of student who
usually made the top half of the class
possible I'll wait for a second to see
if the translators can figure out a ways
to express that in other languages but
since those days all kidding aside I've
become more of them developed my
appreciation of just how important
education is in our world I know of no
social problem that we have that
wouldn't be ameliorated or eliminated if
we had better public schools and that
has to be where our focus is it is the
future of our city it is the future of
our state it is the future of our
country and in fact it is the future of
the world and all of our children of no
matter where they are no matter what the
background is deserve a great public
education and if we don't give them that
we will all suffer from Helsinki to Hong
Kong from Manila to Montreal the city's
represented in the summit I think for
striking contrast to one another and
climate and in geography and in history
and in culture but they also have
something in common and that's what's
brought us here today all of them
recognize that those who dare to teach
must also always be willing to learn and
our schools today have to embrace change
because in every corner of the globe our
schools all confront to his part
historic challenges the first is posed
by the economic realities that we all
face because the world's economy
continues to be transformed in ways that
have profound implications for education
as Lou Gerstner the former CEO of
American Express in IBM recently
commented most jobs that will have good
prospects in the future will be
complicated they will involve being able
to juggle data symbols and computer
programs no matter what the task and no
matter where we're from
those words ring true for all of us now
the path to security and prosperity for
the people we serve in every nation
represented here today runs straight
through the classroom and that's what I
want to talk about the second great
challenge for our schools is demographic
today for the first time in the long
history of life on Earth the majority of
the world's people are city dwellers and
by the year 2050 fully three-fourths of
the people on earth are expected to be
living in cities and as a result in
cities everywhere on the globe whether
our population are growing because of
immigration or in migration our schools
will now all faced a similar and
enormous task preparing vastly increased
numbers of new students often the
children of parents who are themselves
newcomers to city life to succeed in an
increasingly globalized urbanized world
this summit focuses on ways to help our
schools meet these historic challenges
and that includes exploring innovative
approaches to teaching seeing how others
have succeeded in turning around
historically low performing schools and
looking at new ways to prepare students
for the demands of colleges or careers
we just cannot continue to do things in
education the way we did them a hundred
years ago there is no other part of
society will we do that and we've got to
make sure that we responsible for
education whether with a teacher in the
classroom in front of the child which in
the end is the way we deliver the
service and the month number one key in
making sure that child learns or people
all the way up through the taxpayers
that are paying for it we just have to
be willing to try new things because we
are living in a different world now we
all have a lot to learn Americans I've
always thought perhaps more than others
many of us can remember when the
educational system of the United States
was the envy of the world but we
recognize that America's scholastic
standing has now slipped badly and we've
gotta focus on that and understand
what's happened to us and make sure that
we stop that trend today we find
America's students ranked 20
in the world in high school graduation
rates 21st in science and 25th in math
and while other nations have raced ahead
expecting more of this students and
teachers expecting more from their
students and teachers America has Stood
Still even though we've been spending
far more than anybody else in the whole
world and cutting cutting class size far
below what it used to be now let me be
clear we don't begrudge the great
successes that schools elsewhere
including some of your schools have had
you have earned it on the contrary we
want to learn from you and do even
better that's what America is all about
we don't begrudge success we want to
make sure that everybody succeeds and it
is what built this country and that kind
of single-minded devotion to improving
education has characterized our
administration since we came into office
back in 2002 when we started New York
City school system was widely considered
to be one of the worst in the nation one
that year after year utterly failed to
educate too many of our children and the
key reason for that failure was evident
to all it was a governance structure
that segmented authority over schools so
that local officials were effectively
shielded from being held accountable for
school performance well it's true in
business it's during government it's
true in every field when there is no
accountability here's what you
inevitably get lousy results and no
reason to improve them so as a first
step we campaign hard to gain authority
for our state leaders to assume control
of an accountability for new york city's
public schools themselves and there's
somebody sitting in this room who
deserves an enormous amount of credit
for actually helping us to achieve it it
is the hundred n sixth mayor of the city
of New York David Dinkins and he with
his predecessor Ed Koch and his
successor Rudy Giuliani the three of
them worked very hard to get mayoral
control and acted Joel and I were the
beneficiaries of coming along at the
right time but you know we build on
those before us and we stood on
shoulders and without the work of all
three of those we never would have
gotten this done when we finally got
control of the schools we seized it as
an opportunity to make dramatic and
fundamental changes and in the process
it's fair to say that we have
transformed our school system from one
of the nation's worse to one that
President Obama's administration has
identified as a model for cities in the
rest of America that transformation
rests on a new culture of accountability
it's the basis for all of the reforms
that with the visionary and vigorous
leadership of schools chancellor Joel
Klein we have instituted for example
when schools have chronically failed to
help students advance elastically we've
closed them down we've given greater
authority to principles including the
authority to decide what works and what
doesn't work in their individual schools
with the student body that they have and
the physical resources that they have
we've ended the practice of social
promotion which for years move children
up a grade even if they hadn't mastered
the necessary skills to do the grade
that they were in what a tragedy a child
is falling behind and we put them into a
more difficult environment what would
any of us do if we SAT there and just
totally understood that we didn't
understand anything going on at the head
of the class we stop that process it was
controversial but today I think people
would look back and say if it wasn't for
Joel's idea and if we didn't get that
done we could not make most of the
progress that we have made and by
encouraging the creation of hundreds of
new academically challenging schools
including charter schools we've
introduced greater competition into the
entire school system that makes all of
the schools stand or fall on the results
they produce and challenge them to do
even better about six months ago US news
and world report listed the hundred best
public high schools in the country and
I'm happy to say twelve or New York City
public high schools in the entire
country we got twelve percent right here
with three percent of the country's
population
the graduation rates as mayor said orly
said that will one stagnant have grown
up every single year they are
twenty-seven percent higher than they
were four years ago compared to just a
three percent rise among students who
face the same requirements in the rest
of our state our african-american and
Hispanic students have substantially
narrowed the achievement gap that for
far too long has separated them from
their white and Asian counterparts a
shameful fact I'm pleased to say that we
have helped to change we still have a
long ways to go but when you compare the
students within the state who all take
the same tests I don't know whether the
tests are harder or easier it's not
worth having that debate they all take
the same tests and so these comparisons
are a very fair ways to measure it and
by any standard New York City students
have done better than the rest of the
state and by any standards we have we
have cut substantially into that
disgraceful gap that has been existing
for far too long when people just threw
up the hands and says that's where it is
and there's nothing we can do about it
now I said we still have a long ways to
go because for example even while our
graduation rates have climbed
dramatically it's still the case that
more than a third of our students don't
complete high school within four years
and too many who do graduate still lack
the academic skills they need for
success let me also point out that
another thing we've been able to do
while not every child can get through
high school in four years the number of
children who are staying around for a
fifth and sixth year rather than
dropping out has gone up substantially
as well and in many senses that's what I
think we should be most proud of not
everybody learns at the same pace not
everybody has the same social support at
home where the freedom to go to school
every day but if a child cares enough to
stand around and work as hard as they
can stay around and work as hard as they
can and graduate in five or six years my
hat's off to them too many of our
graduates however still lack the
academic skills they need for success in
the real world
and so to build on our achievements
today we have now set this goal making
sure that all our students leave school
ready for college or careers college is
not right for everyone sometimes maybe
you'll go back later on sometimes
economic necessities force you to go to
work to support your family that's what
America is about it's about people
taking responsibility and working and
I've made sure that our next school's
chancellor Kathy black comes to our
Department of Education with the top
flight management experience and skills
that qualify her superbly to guide this
effort Joel and I worked very hard to
find somebody who can take what Joel's
done and carry it on and when this
administration finishes the end of 20
2013 we've got to make sure that we as
citizens of New York citizens of this
state citizens of America citizens of
the world make sure that all of the
changes that we've made all of the
improvements that we've made don't get
turned around and go back to where we
came from we cannot do that for our
students we owe them more we have to
make sure that every teacher in every
classroom is an excellent teacher New
York City has blessed with is blessed
with 80,000 teachers it's an astonishing
number and most do a phenomenal job in
fact as our schools have improved new
teachers have been flocking here from
across the nation because they want to
be part of the success story being
written in New York City we want them
very much because we know that the most
significant factor affecting any
students performance is the quality of
his or her teacher yet I'm sad to say
unlike in other professions teaching is
still organized on what might be called
a factory model with teachers regardless
of the mastery rewarded primarily for
their longevity on the job and to alter
that we're reforming how we award
teacher tenure which is a vital
career-long guarantee of job security
for many years teachers were granted
tenure automatically by default instead
it should be an honor earn
outstanding achievement the rest of us
have to face that kind of competition
and accountability and everything else
we do in society demands that we do it
in perhaps the most important endeavor
that we are engaged in educating the
future of our world so within the next
few weeks will present teachers and
principals in our public schools we
think with a new fair and detailed
framework for how teachers tenure
decisions we made it's a process that
will focus on teacher effectiveness in
helping students learn and grow over the
course of the year especially struggling
students for whom English is not their
first language and students with
learning disabilities we live in a very
complex world we live in a global world
we have a lot of students who join our
school system they come here from around
the world and they don't speak English
and it's up to us to make sure they
still get an education we have a lot of
students who come here who aren't
blessed with a big stable family that
can support them we have to make sure
that they have opportunities and get the
support in the school system that they
should be getting at home but just by
the luck of the draw don't we have to
make sure that every student no matter
what hand God dealt them in terms of
abilities physical mental whatever gets
a chance to participate in the great
American dream and we will continue to
improve the school system continue to
improve the quality of teachers work
with the parents do everything we can we
have budget problems like everybody else
we will find a ways to make sure that
there is a great teacher in front of
every child in our school system we owe
the world at least that and we're going
to help our teachers enhance their
careers enhance their abilities we are
not going to fail and our teachers are
not going to fail this morning many
thousands of parents across the city
woke up well before dawn to make
breakfast lay out clean clothes and get
the children ready for a new school day
they took their children's hand in
theirs and they guided them to the
schoolhouse doors sometimes with an hour
or an hour and a half subway ride there
are students that have to take a subway
and a bus and a boat to
to the school that they want to go to
but when I talk to parents on the subway
in the morning the parents no matter how
long their commute every single one of
them looks me in the eye and says thank
you for improving our school system my
child is into the most wonderful school
in the city and I say how long's your
commute oh it's only an hour and a half
if that's the sacrifice parents have to
make to get their children in to a great
school that's what they do it is our
responsibility to once the parent drops
the child off at the schoolhouse door
leaving their children in our trust to
make sure that we do our part and each
day seems like I've described get played
out in their cities that means we have
an enormous responsibility a
responsibility to do the utmost for
children they're our future and it's
really that simple and that profound and
it's also that exhilarating because it
means it is in the power of our hands to
make an enormous difference and ensure
that the best days for the cities that
we live in the countries that we live in
and loved the world that gives us
opportunities will have a great future
it's why our teachers have to be held
accountable it's why you and I have to
be held accountable and it's where why
we have to find new ways to do our best
and that's what this summit is really
all about so from those of you from
elsewhere outside the city around the
world or across the country do two
things for me most importantly is try to
share ideas with each other because we
all can learn from each other and number
two please spend some money in the
stores here we need the sales tax
revenues to pay for our educational
system enjoy your stay in the city and
thank you
you